how important you think it is for the
area for the local community you know
this culture that the carnival brings
out it's very important that they call
it the card okay so that's yeah that's a
bit of paint for me great come on it was
right I'll hand back to you guys anybody
paint is interfering with the signal Joe
yeah you've got a Joe if you're gonna be
down there you've got to get into the
spirit of it it's just the way of it I
should have wore my overalls
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
like in the next hour shall we
I tell you what I'm sure it can
expensive do for that Oh Joe
well it's carnival it's carnival what
can you expect getting in the mood of it
all